an opinion piece in the new york post
argues this of course biden's policies
are to blame for this migrant tragedy
our border resembles what in the law is
called an attractive nuisance like a
swimming pool without a fence biden's
policies lure people here with promises
that they'll be able to live here
forever without any meaningful chance of
deportation if only they can make it
past the border jason shea fitz fox news
contributor former republican
congressman from utah is here to call
this a closed border
is a new level of
insanity it's much worse than putin's
price hike because people are dying
because of our border
policies
hey can you imagine how horrific the
scene must have been in in there that
the heat
the
exhaustion you have more 53 people dead
it says totally preventable the border
is not closed and for the white house
spokesperson to say that they're focused
on this joe biden has never been to the
border ever the kamala harris is
supposedly the border are she has done
absolutely nothing andreanda the the um
secretary for homeland security is
saying that the border is under
operational control that's a lie it is
absolutely totally not and that's not
just me dagon or somebody else making
this comment that's the border patrol
themselves how come these senior
officials will not meet take the time to
meet with people like brandon judd in
the border patrol and talk to any one of
the tens of thousands of agents that are
trying to do this job it is a magnet it
is drug trafficking it is human
trafficking it is one of the greatest
tragedies and it's totally preventable
as the mark lamb of panel county arizona
the sheriff there said yesterday when we
were talking about this horrific tragedy
and the inhumane treatment of migrants
who were just trying to get into the
united states he said just google u-haul
and migrant and over and over and over
again uh that you there are story after
story since joe biden took office of
migrants adults and even unaccompanied
children found crammed in small un
ventilated vehicles even last
last june there were 33 migrants found
in a u-haul in a hundred degree heat and
so they stand back and let this happen
and let these traffickers these drug
traffickers and human traffickers profit
from human suffering and misery whether
it's fentanyl deaths or whether it's
migrants dying in the back of a tractor
trailer they're standing back lying and
letting it happen
yeah
you talk to the border patrol agents
they'll tell you that more than half of
the women that are coming across and
smuggled are being raped along the way
and how about the fentanyl i mean we
just did stories about fentanyl and the
drug trade that's coming across killing
americans i mean by the hundreds on a
daily basis
this is totally preventable and for the
white house to pretend that they have an
action plan that they have it under
control that the borders close is just
absolutely fiction and a lie why are we
hitting all-time record highs numbers
that are so big since we ever started
counting it's because the biden-harris
administration is tacitly
responsible for this they've attracted
them they told them they're not going to
be deported live the american dream just
get here come here as fast as you can
and they've done so by the millions
border apprehensions at a new record
fentanyl seizures in two months uh
enough the same amount of fentanyl is
being seized right now that we they used
to seize in a complete 12-month of
fiscal year i i want to move on to this
critics are digging in after a newly
released 2018 voicemail from president
biden to his son hunter seems to prove
that he was asking his son
about his business dealings with china
former doj prosecutor jim trustee called
it an integrity test quote will they
walk away from powerful evidence will
they come up with a soft plea like a tax
charge talking about justice
that does not remotely capture the
actual wrongdoing will they treat hunter
biden like any other white-collar
defendant in the federal system kentucky
congressman and house oversight
committee member james comer says
republicans are committed to getting
answers
i've got some bad news for the
mainstream media and democrat leaders in
washington joe biden did have knowledge
of hunter's shady business dealings he
was involved this is going to come out
if it doesn't come out because of
anything that
merit garland or the department of
justice does i can assure the american
people that there's going to be a
hearing early on in a new republican
majority that's going to bring a lot of
these concerns to light
jason
look we know that the bidens had been
doing personal business in china in
russia in ukraine
mexico romania you have pictures of joe
biden with hunter biden's business
partners on a golf course at the uh at
the residence there the vice president's
uh residents you have emails you have
text messages now you have voicemails
that you can listen to how much more
information do they need in order to
justify this when the president united
states and when he was a candidate of
the united states candidate for
presidency said i've never even had a
conversation with him and when you have
about his business dealings but when you
listen to that voicemail it's obvious
that they had had a conversation before
that he was responding and telling
hunter hey i think you're in a clear
i found it among other things odd that a
son would save this voicemail from his
dad
that hunter biden would save this
voicemail
i know that he
may be a reckless addict
but maybe a son keeping leverage over
his own father
raising that question i don't know but
we need a special prosecutor that's what
it's going to take thank you jason jason
chaffetz hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now